we are at an uh
off time from our usual meeting so that
may um impact attendance some though
people uh seem to be filing in to our
virtual room um so i want to welcome
everyone to a special tuesday edition of
the d mice research conference today
uh we're going to hear from jennifer
sullivan who as most in the audience
know is a phd student and national
library medicine fellow in our
biomedical informatics graduate program
she um
has
she received her bachelor's degree in
commerce from santa clara university in
2010 and then
completed a post-baccalaureate health
professions program at uc berkeley
extension in 2017.
she joined our program in july of 2018
as a bioinformatics and computational
biomedicine
um student
and her um advisors are shannon mcweeney
and ronan schweitzer who i see is here
in the audience
and um
also um you know also guan ming and
andrew
okay great guan ming yes and and andrew
um
daddy 80 however pronounce it sorry um
anyways um
um she will she has an interest in
computational methods for understanding
rare disorder and using rare disorders
and using genomics data to understand
development of the musculoskeletal
system and so she has worked under their
met their mentorship and focused on
using single cell transcriptomics to
study the development of tendons
so
she is uh going to give her symposium
today which um as most of you know is
the first
step towards working towards a
dissertation um and she'll complete this
symposium which gives background on her
work as she formulates her research
questions for her dissertation we will
hear back from her um in the not too
distant future for her dissertation
proposal defense and then ultimately her
dissertation defense
so i will um turn it over to jennifer
all right great well thank you for the
introduction
um and uh yeah so i'll be presenting on
investigating mechanisms of rare
disorders through the prediction of
disease gene associations
and i would like to begin my
presentation by sharing a personal story
with all of you
it's not amazing
okay
so um this was me shortly after i was
born
my birth was normal with the exception
of two broken bones and very obvious
contractures of all the joints in my
limbs
meaning my joints were very tight and
stiff
because of the contractures and my very
thin delicate bones i had been whisked
away to the neonatal intensive care unit
where i ended up spending the first 10
days of my life so that's where i am in
this picture
due to physical therapy i'm actually
looking quite a bit better here but at
the time of my birth i was a tight
little bundle and my parents said that i
looked like a little football
something that you can still see in this
picture is this sort of tangled look to
my legs again due to the contractures
after the 10 days in the nicu and
multiple incorrect diagnoses i was sent
home with no diagnosis except for a
statement that i had severe
arthrogryposis multiplex congenita which
refers to my multiple contractures and
is not actually a diagnosis as i will
explain later in my presentation
my parents had no explanation for what
had caused my congenital malformation
so far i had fortunately been able to
breathe on my own as well as smile cry
and open my eyes
but beyond that i had made no other
movements
my muscles in both my limbs and my trunk
were hypotonic and extremely weak
my parents didn't know if i would ever
be able to move
my story describes my first days living
with a rare disorder
with no diagnosis my case is an n of one
unable to be labeled and grouped with
anyone else
even with my designation of having
arthrogryposis i am a member of a small
group because of the small numbers of
people affected by individual rare
disorders most of these disorders have
received relatively little attention
from the scientific community
still although the specific details of
my story are unique
the story of someone having a rare
disorder is not rare at all
in fact the truth is that rare disorders
are quite common
in this presentation i will be talking
about a certain class of methods that
can be used to understand rare disorders
specifically methods for predicting
disease genes
i'll begin by talking about
the impact of rare disease and why we
should care about developing methods for
the rare disease community despite the
small number of individuals with any
given disorder
i will also discuss some of the biggest
challenges in rare disease research
i will then talk about gene prediction
and how it can be used to investigate
rare disorders
finally i will review the prior work to
develop methods in this area
and i will highlight opportunities for
the development of new methods
so what is the impact of rare disorders
in the united states the orphan drug act
of 1983 defined a rare disorder as one
that affects fewer than 200 000 people
in the u.s
based on this definition there are about
seven thousand disorders that are
considered rare
within the united states an estimated 25
to 30 million people have a rare
disorder
that's about one out of every 10 people
based on the eu's definition of a rare
disorder as one that is life-threatening
or chronically debilitating and that
affects fewer than one out of every two
thousand people the global prevalence
was estimated in 2019 to be between 263
and 446 million people or about three
and a half to six percent of the world's
population
an estimated 70 of rare disorders begin
before birth or during childhood
and another 18 percent can be uh can
begin in either children or adults
this means that most rare disorders are
lifelong ordeals and in many cases are
fatal early in life
rare disorders affect people's lives in
more ways than simply the physical
manifestations
a survey of over 1 000 adults living
with a rare disorder revealed that
individuals with rare diseases tend to
have worse quality of life outcomes than
not only the general population but also
those living with chronic conditions
that are more common
so why would that be the case
another study suggested that the very
fact that the disorder was rare
introduced additional challenges
especially due to the lack of knowledge
about the disorder by health care
professionals
due to the dearth of research on rare
disorders the so-called diagnostic
odyssey that many rare disease patients
go through can last many years
even if a correct diagnosis is
determined there's often little
information that can be offered about
the mechanism of the disease let alone
any treatment
in my case although no one knew what had
caused my condition i was fortunate that
there were some treatments available to
try to reduce my contractures and build
up some muscle
throughout the early years of my
childhood my treatments consisted of
physical and occupational therapy
orthotic devices such as splints casts
and braces
and at least six surgeries
through these treatments i did gradually
gain some strength and flexibility
however even with these early victories
the effectiveness of these methods was
still quite limited
at the age of three i was given perhaps
my most important prescription
a license to drive
yes my first hot rod was pink
i have lived my life unable to walk or
even stand and while i am lucky to be
mostly independent throughout the day i
am still fully reliant on assistance for
various activities of daily living such
as simply getting in and out of bed
currently there are no treatments that
directly target the cellular and
molecular changes that produced my
condition the startling reality is that
over 90
of rare disorders do not have an fda
approved treatment
but this doesn't have to be the case
with computational methods that can
address the challenges of rare disorders
we can begin to understand the
biological processes behind them and
start to bring down the number of
disorders without treatment
so now that we have a better picture of
the impact of rare disorders
let's discuss some of the biggest
challenges in researching rare disease
the main challenge facing research on
individual rare disorders is limited
data
when studying a common disorder a
typical computational design might look
something like this
a researcher collects some kind of data
type from the patients in a large study
such as one or maybe a combination of
these omics data types
this data is then associated with the
patient's phenotype data or other
metadata to train and validate a model
that predicts the phenotype or other
patient outcome
the model created can then be used
either for prediction of unknown
outcomes in new patients
or as a way to infer which variables
such as genes are most likely involved
in producing the observed outcomes
however this type of study may require
hundreds to thousands of patients
in reality the challenge of limited data
is not specific to rare disease so the
methods i will talk about can be useful
for more common conditions as well but
rare disorders do represent an extreme
challenge in this regard as their much
sparser patient populations make
recruitment and data collection a much
more challenging and prolonged process
in addition to the issue of limited data
there are also biological challenges
that must be considered
rare disorders may sometimes seem
relatively simple
it has been estimated that 80 percent of
rare disorders are genetic in origin
and these are mostly believed to be
mendelian meaning they are caused by
just one gene
so a fair question might be
why don't we just treat each disorder
individually by editing the mutations in
each of these genes
in the long run this may be something
that needs to happen at least for some
disorders
however this strategy will not be enough
in addition to this approach currently
being intractable
there are also a number of other issues
that will necessitate a different
strategy
one that is focused not on any
individual gene but on the actual
disease process itself
to talk about the biological challenges
of rare disorders i will use
arthrogryposis multiplex congenita or
what i will simply call arthrogryposis
as a case study
understanding these challenges will be
important for understanding how gene
prediction methods can provide new
insights into rare diseases
when i told my story i mentioned that i
had been labeled as having
arthrogryposis multiplex congenita but
that this was not an actual diagnosis
this is because arthrogryposis is not a
single disorder
rather it is the medical term used to
describe the presence of contractures or
stiff joints
that are present at birth in multiple
areas of the body
in other words it is a phenotype
it turns out that this phenotype is a
characteristic of over 400 different
disorders
so far mutations in more than 400 genes
have been associated with arthrogryposis
and like most other rare diseases many
of the disorders presenting with
arthrogryposis are believed to be caused
by just a single gene
but let's discuss some of the biological
complexities that must be considered
the first complexity is that for
arthrogryposis as for many rare
disorders a causative mutated gene is
not the whole story
the current consensus is that the
contractures develop in two phases
in the first phase a mutation causes
fetal
fetal akinesia or reduced fetal movement
in the second phase it is actually not
the initial mutation but the reduction
in movement that has been shown to
produce contractures through changes to
the tissues in in and around the joint
this means that while repairing the
mutated gene may be important it will
likely not be enough to restore normal
function once the contractures have
already formed
the second challenge is that
arthrogryposis is not always caused by a
mutated gene
in fact the most common disorder
presenting with arthrogryposis
amyoplasia as a is sporadic with no
evidence so far of a genetic origin
consistent with the concept that
restricted movement leads to contracture
the evidence suggests that anything that
disrupts the development or function of
the tissues that are necessary for
movement of the fetus can produce
arthrogryposis
along with mutated genes
this includes dozens of environmental
factors which suggest that some cases of
arthrogryposis may involve changes to
the epigenome rather than the genetic
code itself
in addition diagnostic efforts for
patients with arthrogryposis
diagnostic efforts for patients with
arthrogryposis have focused so far on
mutations in the coding regions of the
genome yet many patients remain
undiagnosed
if these undiagnosed patients do have a
genetic cause
it may be that their mutations lie in
non-coding regions
such as regulatory elements
we can see then that the heterogeneous
etiology complex progression
and extensive histopathological changes
of arthrogryposis create a complicated
picture that requires us to look beyond
individual genes
this figure shows biomolecular pathways
that are enriched for many of the genes
associated with arthrogryposis
some of these pathways seem to have more
obvious connections to movement and
therefore to the generation of
arthrogryposis
while others may have significant though
perhaps less straightforward
contributions
this set of genes and pathways
represents our existing knowledge of the
initial processes leading to
arthrogryposis
we can understand if we can understand
how these genes relate not only to one
another
but also to other genes and the pathways
that those genes are involved in we will
have a much stronger starting point from
which to understand the processes
that result in congenital contracture
beyond arthrogryposis understanding the
genes and pathways involved in other
phenotypes and rare disorders
will help us to understand their
mechanisms as well
disease gene prediction methods can help
us to work out these mechanisms by
discovering potential disease genes and
suggesting new molecular pathways and by
prioritizing the best candidates for
validation and further investigation
once the mechanism of disease is more
fully understood gene prediction can
also help with developing treatments by
identifying the genes that may be the
most likely drug target candidates
finally gene prediction can also assist
with shortening patients diagnostic
odyssey
by providing evidence for the
involvement of genes that would
otherwise not be associated with the
patient's disorder
i had mentioned that genes are not
always the cause of rare disorders
later in my presentation i will talk
about ways that gene prediction methods
could be used to go beyond genes to also
consider regulatory elements and their
relationships to genes
so let's talk about gene prediction and
why these methods can help us get around
the challenges of rare disorders
just to be clear when i talk about gene
prediction i am talking about
a method that uses information about a
disorder or phenotype to predict which
genes out of a given set
are involved in generating that disorder
or phenotype
typically the genes are assigned scores
corresponding to their likelihood of
being implicated which enables their
prioritization for validation and
further investigation
a threshold is then used to select the
subset of genes considered to be disease
associated
the set of candidate genes is the set
that is hypothesized to contain at least
one gene involved in the disorder or
phenotype
while the whole genome can be used
limiting the candidates based on
knowledge about the disorder can improve
predictions
a big reason that gene prediction
methods can work well for rare disorders
is that the disease information that is
needed for the model can actually be
quite limited
so let's first view these methods
through the lens of how much we know
about the genes that cause a disorder of
interest
to understand this perspective let's
revisit this figure showing the more
traditional way of investigating a
disorder
again for a rare disease we will likely
not have a large cohort of patients
if there is any any omics data from any
patients with the disorder it will
likely be of just one data type like
whole exome sequencing or maybe rna-seq
so we likely won't be working with a
very large data set
so let's remove these from the picture
now i haven't talked about sources of
prior knowledge yet and those will
certainly come into play but to keep
things simple for now let's also remove
them from the picture
so what can we use as inputs to our
model
well that depends on how much we already
know about the genes involved in the
condition we're investigating
let's first look at the worst case
scenario where we have no information
about any genes associated with the
disorder
here the goal is to just find any genes
that may be linked with this disease
in this scenario the input to the model
could simply be keywords or ontology
terms such as from the human phenotype
ontology or the gene ontology that
pertain to the disorders phenotypes or
biological processes
there are multiple approaches that have
been developed for this problem but they
all involve predicting genes for one
disorder based on its similarity to the
phenotypes of other disorders
these include text mining approaches as
well as methods that use disease gene
association networks and machine
learning
for other disorders we may have
information about genes whose expression
is correlated with the disease phenotype
this might look similar to the scenario
for more common disorders where omics
data is correlated to patients
phenotypes
again though with rare disorders we
likely don't have the patient numbers or
the multiple data types to be able to
train and validate supervised machine
learning models
instead what we have might look more
like this
data from a very small cohort of rare
disease patients and controls
and a single data type such as rna-seq
producing a small data set
in this case we can see changes in
expression
but it's not obvious which genes are
driving the disease state and which ones
are passenger genes more peripheral to
the disease process
for this scenario investigators have
used unsupervised clustering algorithms
to detect disease gene coexpression
modules
rather than returning a list of
individual genes these methods produce
sub-networks of genes that can be
further investigated
finally due to the increasing
availability of sequencing technologies
whole genome and whole exome sequencing
and to a much smaller extent gwas have
identified some of the causal genes for
many rare disorders
these known disease associated genes can
be used as seed genes to aid in the
discovery of additional genes that may
be causal or may otherwise be central to
the biological mechanism of the disorder
with these models you don't need to
collect any omics data from patients
beyond these known disease genes
and this makes these models very
appealing for investigating rare
disorders
there are a number of different types of
methods that use seed genes including
similarity profiling network based
methods and machine learning methods
performed on networks
one thing to note is that even if no
genes have been have yet been discovered
for a disorder there are still ways to
select seed genes to use in the
corresponding methods
one strategy is to focus on just one
phenotype and identify genes linked to
any disorders that present with that
specific phenotype
the set of genes involved in
arthrogryposis are an example of genes
associated with a single phenotype
another possibility is to infer genes
that may be implicated based on their
involvement in similar disorders
in fact many disease gene prediction
methods incorporate a disease similarity
network and are therefore able to accept
either c genes or a diseased term as we
saw before
from which they can in firsy genes from
the disease network
because of this overlap in methods i
will highlight only a few examples when
i talk about using keywords to predict
disease genes
so let's talk about some of the methods
that have been developed
again if we don't know any genes
associated with our disorder of interest
we can use methods that make predictions
based on keywords or ontology terms
some of these methods mine the
literature for associations between
phenotypes and genes
in most cases
these relationships are identified by
statistically assessing their
co-occurrence in published abstracts and
papers
for instance a method called beagle
accepts any keywords such as phenotypes
associated with a disorder and searches
for genes that are mentioned with any of
those keywords in medline abstracts
it assesses the strength of the keyword
gene association by calculating the
jaccard similarity
which compares the number of abstracts
in which a keyword and gene appear
together to the number of abstracts
containing just a keyword or just the
gene
while text mining methods are limited to
genes already documented in the
literature
they may reveal new gene disease
associations that can be the starting
point for further investigation
the other methods that accept keywords
are based on the modular nature of genes
which is the observation that genes that
work toward a common function and
produce a common phenotype
often work together
by looking at disorders that are similar
to the one we are investigating we may
be able to identify genes that are
implicated in our disorder
typically this is done using
network-based methods
for example a method called prince
calculates a score for each disorder in
the omim database based on how similar
its mesh terms are to the disorder of
interest
so for instance if our disorder has a
phenotype of arthrogryposis then another
disorder with a phenotype of muscle
weakness would get a higher similarity
score than a disorder characterized by
osteoarthritis
since arthrogryposis and muscle weakness
are more closely related in the mesh
ontology
these disease similarity scores are then
used as seed values for the associated
disease genes
in a protein-protein interaction network
and prince propagates this information
through the network using a diffusion
algorithm
more recently graph learning methods
have been used to try to learn the most
meaningful relationships in the data
for example a method called prejaphene
embeds a heterogeneous network of
various biological data types
into a lower dimensional representation
to try to extract the most meaningful
representation of the data
it then uses these refined relationships
to construct a new dual layer disease
gene network which it uses to predict
the disease genes
now let's look at a few examples of
methods designed to use expression data
that correlates with the disease state
with these methods we are looking for
groups of genes whose coexpression
patterns
change in the disease samples versus the
control samples
by far the most widely used module
detection method is wgcna
which uses
hierarchical clustering to identify
modules of coexpressed genes across
samples
however while this method may work well
for some applications it may not be the
most effective for zeroing zeroing in on
groups of genes that are driving a
disease process
this is because it identifies
co-expression modules across all samples
before determining their level of
association with the disorder
in contrast while diff coax uses the
same hierarchical clustering process as
wgcna
it first takes into consideration the
changes in coexpression between disease
samples and control samples before
identifying modules
therefore the modules represent sets of
genes that are differentially
co-expressed between cases and controls
and therefore likely to be more directly
related to the actual disease process
in addition these methods can be
improved by incorporating additional
information
for example wu and stein used a
protein-functional interaction network
as evidence of true associations
and they use co-expression data to
weight to the edges of this network
they then perform markov clustering on
this weighted network to identify
coexpression modules
next we'll look at examples of methods
that can use known disease-associated
genes referred to as c genes to inform
their predictions
because c genes are typically directly
related to the mechanism of the disorder
or phenotype the use of seed genes
produces the highest confidence
predictions of genes that are also
involved in the disease process
therefore i will spend more time on this
category
the first class of methods i will talk
about are similarity profiling methods
also known as data fusion or ensemble
methods
genes that perform similar functions or
participate together in a pathway will
often share similar sequences have
overlapping functional annotations be
co-expressed or demonstrate similarity
in other ways
similarity profiling methods use these
similarity characteristics
to statistically determine which
candidate genes have the highest
resemblance to the seed genes that are
input into the model
one of the most commonly used similarity
profiling methods called endeavor
gathers different types of information
about the seed genes by accessing 75
different data sources providing
insights on such characteristics as
function pathway expression patterns
sequence and chemical interactions among
others
it then compares each candidate gene to
the seed genes and calculates a final
aggregated score of similarity
these methods make an assumption that
the various pieces of evidence should
all have an additive effect on a
gene's disease probability
therefore to get around this limitation
machine learning models have been
developed to learn the contributions of
the different evidence sources in
predicting disease genes
for example p brit extracts information
about the genes from various sources and
uses this information along with the
along with the seed genes to train a
bayesian ridge regression model
the great thing about similarity
profiling methods is that they can
easily take an unlimited number of data
sources into account providing a wide
range of evidence for possible
relationships between seed and candidate
genes
however these methods do not explicitly
model gene's multiple interactions with
one another or consider the complex
association patterns between genes and
other associated data
therefore networks have become a popular
structure used to model the actual
physical interactions and functional
relationships between genes
as well as their associations to other
entities
network-based methods are based on the
principle of guilt by association
again referring to the observation that
genes operate within functional modules
early methods were limited to looking at
the local environment around seed genes
for example
diamond works by first identifying the
direct neighbors of the seed genes and
determining which one is most highly
enriched for c gene connections
that gene is then labeled as another c
gene and the process is
repeated although the process expands
across the full network only direct
neighbors are considered at each
iteration
this assumption that disease genes are
directly connected to the seed genes
introduces the possibility of false
positives and also risks missing genes
that are important to the disease
process
in response to these limitations kohler
at all introduced what would become very
popular methods the random walk with
restart and the diffusion kernel method
these network propagation approaches
measure the strength of the relationship
between two genes based on the
probability of encountering one gene
when traversing the network starting at
the other gene
these methods can also be thought of as
measuring the flow of information
through the network starting at a given
gene
an example from the original random walk
paper demonstrates that two genes
separated by another can be scored
differently based on the connectedness
of the gene between them
or based on the number of paths
connecting the two genes
therefore network propagation methods
consider more global topological aspects
than methods based on local
relationships
when i talked about similarity profiling
methods i said that their advantage was
the ability to incorporate many sources
of information about the genes
omics data is inherently noisy
and if we limit our network to just high
confidence curated protein protein
interactions we will likely be missing a
lot of relevant information due to our
incomplete knowledge of these
interaction networks
in addition each individual data source
contains its own biases
because certain genes disorders or other
entities will be more well researched
than others
so an important developments in the
field of disease gene prediction was the
extension of network propagation
algorithms to knowledge graphs
which incorporate information from
multiple data sources
we have seen a couple examples of
heterogeneous knowledge graphs that
incorporate protein-protein interactions
with disease similarity networks
in 2019 valdeo olivas at all went even
further by extending the random walk
with restart algorithm to multiplex
heterogeneous networks
they demonstrated their algorithm by
using it to predict disease genes from a
network that
that connects a disease similarity
network
with three layers of different types of
gene information
global approaches using these various
network propagation methods have become
widely used but are they truly better
than the more local approaches using
direct neighbors or shortest paths
to answer this question shim at all
tested both a local strategy and a
global strategy
and demonstrated that actually neither
of these approaches consistently
outperformed the other in predicting the
top disease genes
instead they show that the performance
of a given approach depended on the
level of connectedness between the
actual disease genes
the method
that focused on local properties was
better at prediction for disorders with
highly connected genes whereas the
method focusing on global properties was
better at prediction for disorders with
genes that were more dispersed
throughout a pathway
for some disorders the implicated genes
are partially connected in a pathway and
may require a combination strategy
more generally we don't know what the
true patterns of connection are between
many of the genes which prevents us from
choosing the most optimum strategy
to try to get the best of both of these
approaches machine learning methods can
be used
with machine learning both local and
global topological features can be
selected as input to a model and the
model can be trained to weight these
features appropriately to obtain the
best prediction
for example ramadan it's all developed a
random forest model
using 13 topological features from their
network some of them local like degree
and shortest path measurements
and some of them global like random walk
measurements
one challenge that the task of disease
gene prediction poses to traditional
machine learning models
is the fact that only positive training
samples referring to the c genes are
known
whereas the class label for the vast
majority of training samples the
candidate genes
is unknown
therefore the model has no definite
examples of non-disease genes from which
to learn as a result a special class of
machine learning methods that uses
strategies for positive unlabeled
learning
have been applied to this problem as
well
for example catapult uses a biased
support vector machine to predict
disease genes based on random walks of
different lengths
since most of the candidate genes are
likely not involved in the disease
catapult trains the model by selecting a
random subset of candidate genes to
serve as negative examples
the support vector machine is biased
because it penalizes false negatives
more more heavily than false positives
since the examples of true positives are
actually known
as an alternative to hand selecting the
features to be used in a model there now
exist methods that can automatically
learn to represent a network structure
as a set of feature vectors
these vectors can then be used for
downstream analyses including as
features in a machine learning model
these graph learning methods include
network embedding and matrix
factorization
as well as deep learning which i will
discuss in the next slide
earlier we saw a method that used
network embedding to learn meaningful
relationships in the data to construct a
more refined network
another example of the use of network
embedding is smudge which uses a random
walk-based embedding model called
skipgram to represent each node's
environments as a vector
these vectors are then used as the
features in a neural network to predict
disease genes
while network embedding methods may
perform very well in certain cases the
embedding process is unsupervised or
semi-supervised so the topological
features that are extracted may or may
not be the most relevant features for
predicting the genes responsible for a
particular disorder
that's where deep learning comes in
because deep learning uses a supervised
strategy to transform the data as well
as
predictions
it actually learns the features that are
most relevant for predicting disease
genes
whether these are topological features
of the network or attributes of
individual genes or other entities
for example pgcn uses a graph
convolutional neural network to
simultaneously embed a gene disease
association network and make predictions
in this case predictions of edges
between diseases and genes
so that gives an idea of the state of
the field
now i'll go ahead and talk about
opportunities for further research and
model development
one thing that i touched on and would
like to emphasize further is the use of
prior knowledge to try to improve gene
predictions
we've seen some examples of this mostly
of methods using protein-protein
interaction or functional networks
disease similarity and disease gene
associations
the incorporation of prior information
is important because this is another key
feature that makes disease gene
prediction methods work so well for rare
disorders
we have seen that the information we get
from rare disease patients is typically
rather limited so we need other inputs
to our models that can help us to
understand the relationships between
genes
incorporating multiple types of prior
information has been shown to improve
the performance of disease gene
prediction methods
for example when valdeo oliva centault
tested their random walk with restart
method for traversing multiplex
heterogeneous networks
they also tried it on simpler networks
with just one or two layers of
information
either protein-protein interactions
pathways coexpression or combinations of
these
using known disease genes for over 200
disorders they found that combining all
three types of gene information produced
the highest ranks for the known disease
genes
and they also added the layer of disease
similarities the performance was even
higher
so one way to improve disease gene
prediction methods
could be to incorporate additional
sources of information
fortunately we are in an era of big data
even if we don't have large amounts of
data for a specific disorder
many consortiums and research groups
have established rich resources of data
collected from normal healthy tissues
and cells
from these healthy samples we can learn
the normal patterns of interaction for
the disease and candidate genes
and use this information to make
predictions
while different types of data should
give us different insights into these
processes some data types appear to
still be underutilized for the task of
disease gene prediction
examples include data types from
resources like encode that provide
insights into the epigenetic regulation
of gene expression
along these lines of improving
performance using prior information you
may have noticed that in valdeo levis's
assessment coexpression data while
helpful did not seem to have a huge
impact on performance relatively
speaking
this is likely because the authors
measured coexpression across 32 tissues
and 45 cell lines
magaret all demonstrated that by
re-weighting a protein protein
interaction network
according to the co-expression of the
specific tissue involved in a disease
they could significantly improve the
performance of their method compared to
when they used a generic protein-protein
interaction network
therefore if the tissues involved in a
disorder are known
then the expression patterns specific to
those tissues could be used to refine
the network
the last few years have seen the
generation of single cell data for many
healthy tissues at various developmental
stages
these data types provide a level of
granularity that may allow for the
determination of different disease gene
networks for specific cell types
another opportunity involves extending
these methods to provide greater insight
into the mechanisms of diseases
while the prediction of disease genes
can advance our understanding of the
disease process by suggesting the
involvement of enriched pathways and
prioritizing genes for further study
there may be additional insights
to be gleaned using the methods that i
have discussed
again the incorporation of additional
data types may help us here
for example
we can incorporate different types of
epigenomic data with gene interaction
data
from this network we might be able to
tell for instance
if one of the predicted genes is a
transcription factor
that binds to an enhancer
that regulates other known and predicted
disease genes
in other words we could determine
whether there might be patterns of
co-regulation
based on the connectivity of predicted
disease genes to regulatory factors
being able to discover these sorts of
connections should help in interpreting
the results of a disease gene prediction
method especially for graph learning
methods that are more of a black box in
terms of feature selection and the
patterns they find in the network
finally the last opportunity i will
discuss is developing an improved method
for dealing with the issue of unlabeled
data
in addition to the approach i discussed
earlier another is to try to identify
high confidence non-disease genes using
different criteria
atta at all suggests the use of
generative adversarial networks to
augment this limited set of labeled
genes
and thereby give the model more labeled
examples to work with
in conclusion we saw that there are
hundreds of millions of people living
with a rare disorder
and that we need ways to understand
disease mechanisms in order to improve
diagnoses and develop the first
treatment for the vast majority of these
disorders
disease gene prediction methods can give
us a good way to study these disorders
because they require relatively little
data from patients with rare diseases
and because researchers have developed
ways to incorporate data from healthy
tissues to improve predictions
by improving and applying methods for
disease gene prediction we can start to
learn the mechanisms of rear disorders
and work toward a world where having a
rare disorder finally is rare
i would like to thank the members of my
dac for their guidance especially in
helping me to find a way to follow my
passion and contribute to the study of
my own rare condition despite the
challenge of having almost no data to
work with
i would also like to thank my fellow
students for their feedback and support
during this process
and thank you to all of you for
attending my talk
and with that i can take any questions
great thank you
um
i'll i will start off with um a question
that's a very
interesting talk
and
[Music]
very
understandable for those of us who are
not down in the weeds on
various omics
you mentioned about epigenetics i was
actually starting to think about that
before you actually mentioned it but
then that raises a larger
thought about
other factors that might impact
expression in the genome environmental
factors things like that
of course there's potentially so many of
them that it may be hard to hone in on
one but is an any thought to
to that kind of data that might um
impact people who have rare disease i
mean even exposure in utero to their
parents or i mean it the combinatorial
explosion is immense but i'm just
curious if you've had any thoughts along
that line
yeah no that's definitely an interesting
route to think about um
you know again i think it'll depend on
whether that data is available for rare
disorders so for some it may be for
others it may not be
uh but yeah no it's definitely an
interesting thought thank you for that
yeah
um
great any other questions you can either
type them in the chat or unmute yourself
and
this is shannon i have one um really
nice talk jennifer really well put
together um
i i think the the thing i was thinking
about as you went through the full
presentation is
you know as you mentioned often there's
one there may be one gene and there's
other pieces like what actually happened
developmentally
um and so it seems like depending on the
phase you're interested are you
interested in like you know prenatal
diagnostics are you interested in
um identification of disease when it's
not known are you interested in
therapeutic options where you're now
thinking about trying to ameliorate
certain effects which no which may you
know resulted from the disease gene but
may actually now be quite downstream and
so i was just wondering have you thought
about where you want to focus on that
because these methods obviously can be
applied in a lot of different ways and
some depending on the question for
example if you're really truly
mechanistic you're thinking much more
about causal inference than you are
about association so just curious where
your your thoughts were leaning in terms
of direction for your dissertation
yeah yeah exactly um i guess that's kind
of why my
focus uh
you know that i put my you know more
focus on the section of using the seed
genes to kind of understand
genes that are sort of directly related
to the mechanism of the disorder
hopefully um
and uh yeah so i'm like in my in my
personal case um since i'm interested in
arthrogryposis um it's kind of an
interesting question because like i said
the initial mutation is not actually
what causes the contractures the
contractors develop after movement stops
um but
um i think
if you're going to use seed genes like
what we have for arthrogryposis
arthrogryposis for instance
is those like initial mutated genes and
so like for me i think it'd be you know
helpful to understand just even those
initial processes what causes movement
to stop in the first place um or you
know at least the
the initial parts of that um
it'll be
you know somewhat
limited you know in terms of how far
along the process we can go until we
kind of
you know understand those initial um
processes and that's kind of what we
have the data for right now if that
makes sense i don't know explain that
well
that's great thanks
so jennifer this is a ronan
so i wanted to ask you about uh
specifically about arthrogryposis since
uh unlike many of the other conditions
that that you're talking about here you
have an embarrassment of genes right
you're
you're looking at a situation with with
a huge number of genes that have been
associated
and i wonder if uh similar approaches
can be used within this group of genes
um
to
try and see if there are analytical uh
ways to to um establish
rank
significance or or interactions between
these or
can can these things be used to can
these approaches be used to to further
uh uh our understanding of mechanisms
within
a
such a large set of of uh defined genes
yeah no definitely i mean if if like
if your goal is to just prioritize the
genes that are already there you can
definitely
use one of these methods or develop a
method that um
you know for
disease gene prioritization
and just kind of use
use those genes that are known as the
candidate genes
um
you might i mean you still have to have
something to kind of
if you're using the seed gene method
you'd have to still use some of the
genes as seed genes you might choose
maybe a subset of those to use
and then try to predict um or you know
prioritize the other genes
um
so yeah it's an interesting question
uh but yeah typically
like when you're doing
validation for instance on on these
methods you would look to you would kind
of hold out a set of the
the the genes that are known to be
involved in a disorder and then kind of
um see if those genes rank highly in in
uh
in the list but that's more for
validation but you i think you could
certainly do it you know something
similar with um
you know actually using these methods
does that answer that
yeah i think i think there's a real
question there of defining a goal for
trying to get out of the analysis
great there's a question from aaron in
the chat um
thanks for a nice talk could you talk a
little about using the vast amount of
genomic data available for patients that
don't have the rare disease of interest
right okay um
yeah so like
okay yeah that's an interesting question
yes i mean um you know i think in that
case you know you would
you
would use a disease similarity network
and then you
could maybe you know like you would have
some sort of protein protein interaction
network and you would have those like
diseased gene
connections and when you kind of either
traverse the network or
learn the properties of the network and
feed that into a model
you know hopefully those
you know connections
um to
genes or whatever omix data you're using
for
the related diseases
um uh you know will
will come out as you know important um
features when kind of predicting the
disease genes
um for your own disease um so that's
kind of how those methods work i don't
know if i'm answering your question if
you want to clarify yeah somewhat i was
just can you hear me
yes i was just thinking that you know
you don't have a whole lot of
information on patients with the disease
but you have a huge amount of
information on
other patients either
patients with a completely unrelated
disease where
you know you'd expect
you know that to
serve as kind of a negative because the
you know expression and interaction and
other things are very
unlikely to be related to the disease so
sort of a contrast
or maybe even you know diseases that
target the same tissue or maybe share
some sort of phenotype
or you know which might have some
similarity in being able to contrast
those two things in the
analysis and machine learning you know
you'd you don't have a lot of positive
cases but you have a lot of
it shouldn't look like this kind of
thing so
you know what's different enough to be
helpful in that way so i don't know the
thought was just that
a judicious and thoughtful selection of
a large amount of negative data might be
useful
yeah definitely actually that's a really
good point um because
it goes to the issue that i that i
talked about of having so much unlabeled
data the candidate genes are unlabeled
uh and so you know
what what some people have tried is you
know exactly what you said look at um
genes that are associated with totally
unrelated disorders and try to use those
genes
as negative examples basically label
those genes as negatives and then have
um
you know your model learned from that or
whatever you're trying to do
um
and so you know in some i know there's
one paper that um you know kind of have
like different categories of like okay
we're these are like high confidence
negatives and then these are
you know somewhat confident negatives
and that sort of thing um so yeah that's
a good that's a good idea yeah i'm
actually going to a little bit more
you know upstream from that we're not
even if you have the you know genomic
data on on labeled patients
you don't have to label the genes as
negative you can have the system label
the genes as negative in contrast to the
few positive patients so you can be even
more upstream and look at those
expression of those negative patients or
you know other other sorts of things
so that you don't have to necessarily
make a binary decision at the gene level
you can make it more at the at the
sample level or the patient data level
that was the thought anyway yeah okay
well thank you
thanks
great probably take one one more
question
or if not um
go ahead i have a quick one this is
nate this is kind of a half-formed um
thought but
i really like uh i loved your
presentation and i like this idea of
using seed genes and protein protein
interaction networks one thought i had
was
um we know we have
kind of
greater or less coverage in certain
areas of the proteome and so
the assumption with these c genes is
that
the right protein protein interactions
are known do you think that there's
maybe
some work to be done or a role in
adding to
those low coverage regions to help
maybe
understand more of the rare disease
interactions
yeah definitely so assuming you're
talking computationally so like maybe
you know using some kind of imputation
or something like that to fill in some
gaps possibly yeah that'd be one thought
um yeah no it's an interesting
idea
i mean you know obviously with that you
want to be careful not to introduce sort
of spurious connections that don't
actually exist but
um
yeah it could be something interesting
to look into
definitely
great well we will um look look forward
to your coming back with your
proposal and and defending it and um
this sounds like some really potentially
exciting work um some of us will uh look
forward to hearing you present at the
nlm trainees meeting in a few months
um so good well thank you everyone for
coming today and um
see you all later take care
thank you